forever forever that is the supreme
desire nothing is real but is not
forever I recently came across an idea
actually that I found disheartening to
say the least there are three types of
deaths in Mexico the first death is when
you learn you're gonna die right the
moment of self-consciousness when you
become awakened to your mortality right
that first moment of being kicked out of
the Garden of Eden that
self-consciousness that I am mortal that
is the first death in Mexico the second
death is uh at the moment that you
actually die right it may be 80 years
after the fact that you first learned
you're mortal but then the moment you
die and you're gone forever and you
become food for worms that's the second
death in Mexico the third death in
Mexico is the last time someone says
your name hmm
you know because it is said that you
live on in the memories of others you
take up real estate in the minds of
others people look at photographs of you
and remember you with fondness but there
might come a point unless you are a
legend that there will be someone who
will be the last person to ever say your
name and that's the third Mexican death
there's a fade dis Wyatt
right that bubbles up in your belly when
you actually contemplate the tragedy of
such a thing the idea that a sentient
mind that a sentient being with the
capacity for self-reflection with a
capacity to love with the capacity to
hope and dream and contemplate and
ponder with a capacity for ecstasy and
agony and anguish and is to become
extinguished by the same cosmos that
engendered that contention aided one's
existence what a joke to
actually fathom non-existence after
salivating and foaming at the mouth at
one's capacity to be Alan Harrington
wrote any philosophy that accepts death
must itself be considered dead it's
questions meaningless its consolations
worn out
you cannot in O War the bitter end you
cannot in knowable the abyss the nothing
as they call it in the neverending story
I don't want the nothing I want
everything there is an urge to carve
one's name on the tree to say I was here
and this meant something and it matters
and it matters